[Musique]
elle est plus que les blacks ça veut
dire quoi pilotes
donc on les initie on leur donne plus
que les rudiments du français certains
arrivent comme pablo par exemple sans
connaître du tout le français et quand
on estime qu'ils ont acquis un niveau
suffisant on les intègre en cours
d'année en mathématiques en musique
[Musique]
m
et j'avais préparé en amont aussi une
une petite fiche avec les consignes et
clan français et les traductions que je
me suis aidé à l'aide d'un traducteur en
ukrainien pour l'aider à comprendre les
bases de la séance et surtout les règles
de sécurité
[Musique]
je parlais avec le tableau avec les rues
à en russe et en cognant on a mis bon de
discuter avec les autres élèves et il
discute avec lui en imprégnant et je
vais tradition la traduction lui en
principe
rien
[Musique]
l'équipe
de ça tu dois vraiment lui changer enfin
il vient de ressortir d'un pays en
guerre donc pour lui il faut qu'ils
seraient habitués à un pays libre entre
guillemets
[Musique]